before we get into captive state so what
what exactly happened I have to start
with what happened with gambit that and
then we also you were on halo for a
little bit yeah I mean look it happens
often with with projects unfortunately
which there's any number of reasons I
mean a gambit was ultimately you know
I'll be honest about it
Fantastic Four came out did not do very
well for Fox they decided to lower our
budget we were 12 weeks out we couldn't
recover the script needed a huge amount
of rewriting in order to fit that budget
and and ultimately you know powers the
be chose not to go down that road so the
film didn't happen sorry but um and then
of course whatever happened after me
with other directors I I have no idea of
what I do know is that Channing Tatum
and his producing partner Ari Caron and
had an amazing have an amazing idea of
what that movie was gonna be and Josh
said him at the writer as well it was it
was terrific I mean it was really
exciting kind of I sort of Godfather
with with mutants set in the world of
New Orleans with different gangs and
movie yeah of a sword I mean it was a
period film it dealt with the 70s up
until the present day and it and it it
was about kind of mutant gangs and the
notion of what it means to belong
tribalism in the kind of in this sort of
Bayou like sort of environment and
swamps of New Orleans so it would have
been a lot of fun I don't know I know
that Channing sort of worked on the
scripts and making it into a more of a
romantic comedy I think which I read and
it was great it was a very different to
what I was involved in but now Disney
have had the reins so I don't know what
their plans are it's so interesting to
me because I never viewed for me as an
outsider and I'm so sorry we're gonna
get into capital state but I've never
viewed gambit has such a strong
character to carry his own movie that I
was always wondering because I heard
what the budget was going to be and it
was well over a hundred million from
wasn't no the one you were gonna make
yeah I'm completely because I read that
too that someone said it 150 million it
was not okay so I will then it's that's
even more surprising to me then because
the superhero genre Fantastic Four was
an anomaly generally speaking the super
here John was the most popular on the
planet so it seems like no matter what
the movie is it performs it's crazy it
was a really good script to you know
some of those movies can sort of be
ultimately be impressive but not be the
Beltone historian was good yeah Joe
she's great was great
I mean look this is probably getting in
the weeds too much but it's it is
interesting to talk about it's like
invariably what happens with that kind
of process of filmmaking if if people
don't have their ducks in the row is
they'll throw it at the wall they'll
then realize it's not sticking and
they'll then spend 150 million dollars
to get it right now as a filmmaker I've
been through that process and it's
really hard to then end up with a piece
of work that actually functions and has
a cohesive story to it and I think you
know we were in a place both chatting me
read the producers where we didn't want
to have to go through that experience we
wanted to you know set out to make a
particular film and and deliver on that
Angier and so you know the whole process
of reshoots and all of that stuff we
didn't want to go down that road it's
interesting I've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers like it happened with Chris
McQuarrie on the mission movie on I
think both mission movies but especially
the recent one where the production
halfway through you know Tom broke his
ankle they had to stop and he was able
to go in the editing room see all the
footage they had and continue writing
yeah and see what they needed and what
it was working and then you know the
movies spectacular but one of the
reasons even Chris will say is because
we had that break in the middle you know
I could look at everything and I so wish
more films had the ability and budget to
take like two weeks in the middle and
just look at everything
isn't that the Japanese is that is that
where yeah they do it that way often why
he does that I mean a lot of Asian
filmmakers do it what do you
I mean it's it's you shoot a bit you
stand down you know it's we were talking
about this with a friend of us the other
day who's an independent filmmaker who's
just made this really interesting film
about Ted Kaczynski and he's shot it
over an entire year like shot a little
bit stops you know and and what it's
allowed him to do is understand the
movie and cut things try things out
rewrite and and the studio system
doesn't really allow for that because it
costs two hundred thousand dollars a day
to be on ER on a studio set the other
thing is that I think that often in the
in the studio format you know there's so
much on the line that they don't allow
you know a single creative mind to drive
that process so there's sort of focus
groups and lots of people who come in
and it feels like it's more of a panic
situation where they're you know
spending the money at the end to sort of
band-aid over problems
you